Готелі, заводи, курорти, вокзали,
дороги та навіть острів Хортиця й
Чорнобильска зона відчуження -
українська влада шукає охочих купити державне майно
або принаймні вкласти гроші у великі
інфраструктурні й комерційні проекти.
- Україну повинна накрити лавина з інвестицій:
як зовнішніх, так і внутрішніх.
Щоб ця лавина таки зійшла, уряд дозволив
виставити на продаж понад 500 об’єктів так званої
малої приватизації та більше 20 великих
підприємств зі стартовою ціною понад 250 млн гривень.
Електронні торги за об’єкти малої приватизації
вже активно йдуть, а от великі активи
продаватимуть не раніше осені.
- У портфелі Фонду держмайна знаходиться
23 об'єкти великої приватизації. Процес, процедура
виведення їх для інвестицій займає приблизно
9 місяців. Це вибір радника, це аудит, це маркетинг
і потім аукціон.
Одним із першим відомих об’єктів, який виставлять
на продаж уже навесні цього року, стане
київський готель "Дніпро". Розташований у самому
центрі столиці, з багатою історією і великим
номерним фондом - його стартова ціна складе
10 мільйонів доларів. Аби фінальна вартість
стала в рази більшою, днями тут призначили
нову директорку. Їй у вкрай стислі терміни
і без залучення додаткових грошей треба
перетворити готель у привабливий бізнес-актив.
- Є такий дуже цікавий момент для готельєрів.
Кажуть: який твій unique selling point?
І завжди готелі, в яких я працювала, вони були
в непоганих локаціях, і казали: location, location, location.
Цей готель знаходиться в самому центрі міста,
і ви самі можете побачити, які тут відкриваються
краєвиди. Це велика цінність для гостей
і це дуже велика цінність для інвестора.
Окрім готелю "Дніпро", до приватизації готують
також готель "Президент" та, ймовірно, "Україну".
У п’ятірці великих підприємств, на які  вже цього року
чекає приватизація, - "Об’єднана гірничо-хімічна компанія",
"Елетроважмаш", шахта "Краснолиманська"
та Одеський припортовий завод.
Довкола приватизації останнього пристрасті не вщухають роками.
Незадовго до виходу цього сюжету затримали
трьох осіб, які намагалися дати хабар
у 5 мільйонів доларів голові Фонду держмайна
за призначення директора підприємства.
На думку експертів, попри загалом позитивний
інвестиційний клімат, є, однак, і низка факторів,
які стримують іноземних інвесторів від ведення бізнесу в Україні.
- Коли інвестор приходить в Україну, він не питає:
"Скажи мені, як заробити?" Він каже: "Стоп!
Я знаю, як заробити. Забезпеч мені безпеку моїх інвестицій.
І от із безпекою інвестиції наразі в Україні
є найбільша проблема. Це, з одного боку,
українські суди, які виносять неправосудні рішення,
ми це всі знаємо. З іншого боку, українські силовики,
які чинять тиск на бізнес. Причому це може бути й
іноземний бізнес, і внутрішній бізнес.
І якщо інвесторів турбує, чи безпечно вкладати
гроші в державне майно в Україні, самі українці
переймаються тим, яка доля чекає на підприємства
після їхньої приватизації. Адже до Верховної Ради
внесли законопроєкт, за яким частково можуть бути
передані у власність інвесторам навіть такі
компанії-гіганти, як "Нафтогаз", "Укрзалізниця" та "Укрпошта".
У Фонді держмайна запевняють:
продавати державні компанії абикому не будуть.
В умовах продажу чітко пропишуть
цільове призначення об’єктів, екологічні та соціальні умови,
а в випадку їх порушення майно може піти на реприватизацію.
- Звісно, разом із правоохоронними органами
ми будемо аналізувати покупця. По-перше,
щоб це не були покупці з країни, з якою в нас
відбувається війна. А по-друге, щоб це були ті,
як ми називаємо, компетентні інвестори, які
зацікавлені в розвитку підприємства. Бо якраз
основна політика, основна мета цієї приватизації -
це не є заробити побільше грошей з продажу…
Перше - це знайти компетентного власника, який
буде розвивати чи то підприємство, чи то магазин, чи будівлю.
Повний перелік усіх об’єктів для приватизації
тепер можна побачити на одному сайті. Тут зібрані
фотографії рухомого, нерухомого державного майна
та компаній, є копії документів, інформація
про стартову ціну та можливість подати заявку
для участі в електронних торгах. Утім, для деяких
підприємств шанси отримати нових власників - мінімальні.
- Будь-який час для великої приватизації в Україні
є слушним. На жаль, втрачено забагато цього часу
і деякі об’єкти приватизації, такі як, наприклад,
"Центренерго", вже навряд чи зацікавлять
іноземного інвестора. Просто виходячи з того, що
тренди, тенденції світової економіки, світового мейнстріму…
Ну, дуже важко уявити, як хтось зараз купує вугілля,
бо воно не екологічне просто.
Окрім масштабної пропозиції державного майна,
нинішня влада пропонує інвесторам ще й привілеї
для ведення бізнесу. У Давосі президент
Володимир Зеленський пообіцяв податкові канікули
за мільйонні інвестиції і навіть цілодобову підтримку
спеціальної "няні". Що ж саме робитимуть
ці персональні менеджери, знає Михайло Бечкало,
бо де-факто вони вже не один рік працюють
в урядовій компанії UkraineInvest.
- Покажете нам живих нянь?
- Живих нянь?
Я одна із них, наприклад.
По суті, це інституція, UkraineInvest чи міністерство.
Це більше програма.
Тобто наші інвестиційні менеджери
і в Києві, і в регіонах будуть надавати супровід
інвесторам 24/7, як ми вже робили
три роки останніх, і успішно досить.
Але інвестняня має один винятковий плюс:
це можливість надання інвестиційних стимулів
для інвесторів, які вкладатимуть 100+ мільйонів доларів.
Аби інвесторам було легше зорієнтуватися,
у що ж саме варто вкладати гроші,
урядова організація UkraineІnvest зібрала для них
атлас із 50 пропозиціями співпраці в різних областях країни.
Тут, окрім великих об’єктів приватизації,
декількох обленерго, є й інфраструктурні та рекреаційні проекти.
У співпраці з державою інвесторам пропонують
реконструювати вокзали в Києві, Вінниці, Дніпрі
та інших містах, відремонтувати автомобільні
та залізничні шляхи, лікарні, парки. А ще взяти
в управління декілька аеропортів, розвинути туризм
на Шацьких озерах, Пилипці, Дунаю.
Держава передусім покладає надії на приватизацію,
розраховуючи таким чином вирішити одразу кілька
проблем: позбутися неприбуткових активів,
поповнити державний бюджет і знизити рівень корупції.
Така мета не оригінальна, але в попередні роки
план приватизації вдавалося виконати не більше ніж на 1-3%.
Цього разу, вважають експерти, шанси вищі
через злагодженість дій президента, уряду та парламенту.